hideout aloneness mrs. Carla I was
felling in because I was having problems
every time I bend over I catch a clamp
right up under my right breast okay and
the muscles on the Chester is inside
inside of your chest inside at the
bottom oak inside the body okay and have
you had let me just complain to a doctor
about that anybody look at you yeah I
went to the doctor and she told me that
it was muscle spasm
so she gave me some medicine to take
three times a day did that help you any
yeah it helped me some time I could have
it and then I you know try to scratch it
out and then around and being it be sore
and then it's pot but it'll go okay how
much you weigh um two kids and how tall
are you 5 - ok and 5 - I'd like to see
the vein 110 so you could be a hundred
pounds overweight there ok so the weight
can have something to do with that and
do you have any other issues any skin
plums any eczema dermatitis psoriasis or
asthma or anything yeah I have asthma
and I have like like my bumps on my face
and then I had a hysterectomy June of
2015 and see my every beginning of the
month or the end my breasts get real
sore and tender and I have sharp pains
in it okay alright hang on here a second
Mitch are you there I'm here I'm here
okay now here's Carl oh she's has a
history of asthma she's got some skin
pumps pumping skin on her face
okay could be eczema rosacea or impetigo
any one of those she had a hysterectomy
I'm assuming her uterus was removed but
she still has ovaries so once a month so
she cycles she still gets breast
tenderness her main complaint was she
bends over and she gets pain inside her
chest and then of course she's a hundred
pounds overweight what would you do for
this girl
for other issues I would get her on a
gluten-free diet for one thing and then
I would get her on actually I would get
around to healthy brain in her packs but
then I would also add gluco gel to that
and vitamin d3 and some women's of X and
R 0 found either or both either or both
what would you do for the weight issues
the route of course ok just to reiterate
more detail to what Sean said now you
want to healthy brain your heart packs 4
months a full dose of each of the
products in that pack twice a day you
want to get a hold of the gluco gel I
get 2 large bottles of glue key gelatin
takes 15 of those a day 5 at breakfast 5
at lunch 5 dinner to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
disks between the vertebrae which may be
involved here and bone making bone
itself then you also going to take the
let's see here the Rev okay the Rev take
one bottle of Rev per month and put a
drawerful in your tongue during those
four you scale so you can lose a half a
pound to two pounds a day and for this
breast tenderness on occasion as you go
through your cycles what you want to do
is as Shar says take the woman's FX
which is a quart liquid mixture of herbs
it goes back to the 1850s 1830s lydia
Pinkins formula works like a charm
you go ahead and start with one of those
courts for months and go ahead and take
a tablespoon twice a day and so that one
quart will last a month and a see here
the eczema nazma should show benefit
when you get on your gluten-free diet no
wheat and barley rye oats no fried foods
no processed meats and oils of gluten
and this will help you deal with the
skin and the asthma problems if it's
call every couple weeks
doesn't know how you're doing and we
will walk you through this